But what I wanted to do today was pursue
the discussion of democratic justice.
I talked about it as a semi contextual
idea and that there's a general argument
which we discussed on Monday that
recognizes the subordinate character of a
democratic constraints on the
superordinate goods that people pursue in
different walks of life.
And I said it was a semi
contextual argument, uh,
with the implication that the way you
work that out varies with time and
circumstance.
It varies at different times in the same,
in the same setting,
but then also it varies across settings.
So if we think about,
um,
the traditional family in
America in the 1950s, um,
which is more or less
captured, I think, uh,
at least with respect to governing
children in this picture,
that's of course very different than the
traditional family life we might find a
in South Africa in the 1980s,
uh,
and where you go depends
upon where you start. Um,
and the,
the basic impulse behind democratic
justice as a kind of democratized Berkey
aneurysm. That is to say
it recognizes that, um,
along with the anti enlightened
theorists that we'd been,
we never design institutions are fresh,
rather we redesign institutions that we
inherit and reproduce into the future.
Um,
but we other than just a reproduce
them into the future in a conservative
fashion,
the impulsive democratic justice is to
democratize them as we reproduce them
into the future. And so, um,
when we think about restructuring
the family or restructuring,
uh, the system of education
or restructuring any, uh,
realm of collective activity,
the idea is to take the inherited
systems of norms and practices, uh,
in Bueb the values that
are embedded in them,
learn about them, um, but then not
be on critical. Think we had a,
as we reproduce them into the future,
how they could be restructured
in accordance with the,
the basic impulse of democratic justice,
which is to democratize the power
dimensions of those relationships while
leaving the other dimensions as um,
unsalted as possible.
We want to democratize democracy
is a subordinate guard,
but we do not want to interfere
with the super ordinate. Good.
Any more than necessary.
So that was the,
that is a summary Statement
of what we did on Monday.
But to put some fresh on it,
I thought I would walk you through a
couple of examples of what this means when
you start actually to apply it.
And I've,
I'm going to talk today
about two such examples.
One could concerns governing children and,
and now that concerns a
governing the workplace. Uh,
and I'm gonna walk you through the kind
of reasoning that gets generated if we
try to think about the
exercise of democratizing
these spears of life within the
constraints within the constraints,
um,
of democratic justice.
Now I thought it would be good to start
with governing children because on the
face of it,
it presents the most difficult challenge
for the argument that I sketch it on
Monday.
Namely,
if you want to have some notion
of collective self governance,
uh,
that is that people have a presumptive
say when power is exercised over them.
How's that going to work with children?
And if you want to,
if you want to have some notion of,
of opposition,
how's that going to work with children?
This after all, we don't want, uh,
simply mindless opposition.
We want loyal opposition,
we want informed opposition,
but young children are incapable of that.
They started me capable up opposition,
but not exactly the opposition,
uh,
that we're looking for.
So if you want to say that democratic
justice should a pow apply in all domains
where power is exercised,
this looks like a pretty hard case and
I think it presents unique challenges.
For one thing,
the hierarchies that exist
of a children are inevitable.
And so we have to think about
the opposition side, uh,
of democratic justice in a way
that takes that into account.
On the governance side too,
we're dealing with a situation where
it's impossible for children to make
decisions about their own,
um,
lives. And certainly from
at the very beginning, ah,
there's are going to have to
make those decisions for them.
So on the governance side of the equation,
John Locke had this,
I think exactly right
when he said that. Um, we,
the only basis for disenfranchising
people is necessity.
So if somebody is unable to participate,
then they should be
deprived of the franchise.
But only to the extent that requires.
So for lock,
he said children should be disenfranchised
for their ignorant non age and once
that expires they should
be and franchised.
And he also thought that,
um, with respect to adults,
we shouldn't disenfranchise
people until absolutely necessary.
So, um, we showed an we
might perhaps we would,
we find it necessary to take away people's
driving licenses once they turn 85 or
at least start subjecting them
to annual driving tests. Um,
but that doesn't necessarily mean we
would take away the vote from them. So,
um, the, the, the Loc
basic Locky and impulse is,
um,
is only to disenfranchise when necessary
and no more than is required by
circumstances.
Um,
now that two presents something of a
challenge when you started to think about
children because if you read some
books on the history of childhood,
one of the things you will
quickly discover is that
over the past hundred years
or so, there's been a huge
lengthening of childhood.
We have invented adolescence.
It's adolescence is not a category
that existed a hundred years ago.
Um,
children with ought to be miniature
adults at a much earlier stage.
So if we have lengthened childhood
length and the time at which people are
disenfranchised after all,
uh,
the incidence of adulthood begin to accrue
around 16 and 17 when people can get
driving license and so on, they
can vote now at 18. Uh, but,
uh, the, the, you know, we
still prohibit, uh, the, uh,
imbibing of alcohol until
21. Um, so it's a very,
it's a, it's a gradual exited to
adulthood and it's an elongated status.
Now, there might be justification
for that when you move from a,
an economy that's based on physical Bron,
uh,
to an information based economy
that's based on education.
It may be necessary to lengthen childhood
because it may be necessary for people
to acquire different kinds of skills
that were not needed in the 18th or 19th
century. So there may be a
justification for lengthening childhood.
Uh, and I'll come back to that,
but it needs to be supplied.
The presumption is that you lonely
disenfranchise out of necessity.
Now there have been movements from time
to time to treat children as miniature
adults from the earliest possible age.
It's a famous British school,
Summerhill founded by a man
called a s Neil who died recently.
And Summerhill was famous
for not having any rules.
Uh, and the kids could
do whatever they wanted.
They could go to class or not go to class.
They could go to bed whenever they wanted.
They could come and go.
They simply were no
rules. Uh, and, and, um,
Neil use this as an example. Uh, it was,
it was always held up as a banner by
the children's rights movement as an
example, uh, of what could
be done. And, and the,
the implicit argument against authority
or authority restructures over children
from a very young age.
But I think it was rather
artificial because after all,
Summer Hill Hill was a private
school, um, where they're well to do,
could send it children or what in England
is euphemistically called a public
school, which means a private
school. Um, and it, it,
it was cocooned environment with where
children could make mistakes without
suffering horrendous consequences
of those mistakes. Whereas if,
if you go down, uh, you know, to, uh,
the hill district of new haven and you
imagine 11 and 12 year old children
making the sorts of mistakes that you
could make in Summer Hill school without
consequence for those kids in the
hill district of new haven, uh,
the,
the results would be life changing,
Lee catastrophic and often are so,
um,
the summer hill story is
I think in that sense,
naive about the larger context of power
relations within which education takes
place.
And as we'll see even more explicitly
when I come to talk about the democracy in
the workplace, um, you never,
you always have to look both at the
system of power relations within an
institution,
but then also the larger power context,
the power externalities as I call them,
within which the institution operates.
And so,
um,
I think the Lockian impulse to have a,
a gradual,
um,
a gradual transition to
adulthood makes sense.
And it should be bounded by necessity,
which creates a presumption that if
we're going to lengthen this period of
dependency,
the justification has to be supplied.
Um, so that, that's on the,
on the governance side of the equation.
What about on the opposition
side of the equation?
Because children don't have the capacity
to engage in what we're thinking of
opposition. That is opposition
where you have internalized and,
and understood the values of the
system into which you were born.
And now you are questioning whether
they should be applied into the future.
Um,
there's not going to be much opposition
either of that sword until children are
fairly advanced.
So there's gonna be a very long period
in which neither collective self
governance nor loyal opposition is
going to be in any meaningful sense,
feasible children are going to be stuck
in hierarchical situations and we would,
that is a basic material with
which we have to work. Uh,
how can we think about that?
Well,
one argument that comes to mind once
we've considering inevitably hierarchical
situations is that perhaps
hierarchies can check one another.
If you have an error, inevitably
hierarchical relationship. Um,
and you think about, uh, more
than one hierarchy. This is,
is this as if you like
another version of ambition,
counteracting ambition. You
create more than one, um,
authority structure over children,
uh,
with the expectation that they
can then to some degree have,
um,
competing and to some degree complimentary
competencies and we'll check one
another.
And that's the basic approach that I
take in thinking about democratic justice
as it applies to children.
We can think of children first of
all as having two kinds of interests,
which I call basic interests
and best interests.
So basic interests are rather like
roles as resources in that sense.
My argument is a resources
argument comparable to roses
and a Amartya Sen sends,
which we didn't have time to talk about.
And Ronald Dworkin,
which I mentioned to you briefly and
if you go back to your notes from our
lecture on roles,
you'll see that I
said one of his most important innovations
was to take the focus off welfare and
therefore different measures of
utility and start instead talking about
resources. In his case,
they were primary goods.
So I talk about basic institutions,
a basic resources or basic interests
as those things which it's necessary to
vindicate in order for the person to
survive and thrive in the economy as it's
likely to exist for their lifetime.
And in the political system
governed as a democracy.
Children have an interest in their basic
interests being met and others have an
interest in the basic interests
of children being met.
We all have an interest in the F in the
raising of literate competent people so
that,
um,
they can participate in the democratic
political order in which we're all going
to operate. And then best interests
or something quite different.
The best interests of
children, um, are to,
to thrive as well as possible to
be all they can be, to be happy,
fulfilled, successful human beings, um,
loved and capable of love.
And all of the other things that we think
of that it's important for children to
develop.
Um,
and the argument is that we should think
of this state as the ultimate five do
Seri of children's basic interest and
parents as the ultimate fight Ucra of
children's best interest. This raises
the question, what is a fiduciary?
Goodness. This, this comes from
Loc. When thinking about children,
that lock makes the argument,
uh,
when he's discussing
children, he says, well, um,
I'll put it into 20th century
term words or 21st century words.
But the basic idea is what
do you do if you know you,
you raise your child, you do your
best for them, you, you, you know,
or resources into them.
You pour energy and affection and to them
you do everything right and they turn
around at the age 18 and they say,
you know, your kid says you dad,
I think you're a schmuck. I'm Outta
here. I don't know you anything. Um,
I knew starts slamming your
fist on the table. You say,
after all I've done for you. Dot Dot, dot.
Locke wants to say this
argument doesn't fly.
Why doesn't that fly?
Why doesn't it apply after
all I've done for you?
What's wrong with that argument
as a basis for thinking about
what children are their parents?
You could take this from a [inaudible]
point of view or our roles.
The end point of view thing. Why? Why
is it, why is it a terrible argument?
I've done these things for you now.
You owe it to me to go to law
school or whatever. You guys,
uh, support me in my, in
my all day. Any guesses?
Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Well,
the child has no choice to participate
in the power structure that it's been in
for the past 18 or so years.
Exactly. So, and for Loc
obligation is based on consent,
social contract theory, right? Yeah.
So you've got a ride that's locks reason.
And so he says,
if your child at the age of 18 says,
you're a Schmuck, I'm outta
here. I don't know anything. I'm,
all you can really do is conclude
that you've failed as a parent.
The child doesn't owe you
anything because, and as I said,
it enrolls in terms the fact that this
child is your child is from the child's
point of view,
morally arbitrary they did and
do anything to become your child.
Right? So your, your risks,
your power and authority over the
child is the power or authority of a
fiduciary.
But it's in the nature of a fight.
Ucra arrangement that the child
doesn't owe the fiduciary anything,
right?
You're huge.
You elected to have that child
and you internalize the risk,
um, that, that might happen
when the child turned 18.
So Locke says, you know,
you're basically out of luck.
What you can do is threatened to
disinherit them, but that's about it.
Um,
and indeed I think that might be the best
argument for allowing inherited wealth
ever devised, uh, that
this no other way for,
for parents to control their children.
But in any event,
short of that, you're out of
luck. Okay. So that's the Nate,
the notion of a fiduciary relationship.
The,
the charge does not owe anything to
the five use airy and it the fight.
Do Sarah,
we relationships persists only as long
as the charges in capable of exercising
that authority for themself.
So why,
think of the state as having,
um,
authority of a fight,
use area authority of a basic interests
and the parents having fiduciary
authority over best interest?
Well,
one reason going in is what I've already
mentioned that once you think of an
inevitably hierarchical situation to
some degree you want to have hierarchies.
Checking one another,
ambition counteracting ambition.
But it's not, it's not just that, it's
more than that. If you think about, um,
basic interests, um, these
have to do with survival, um,
basic medical care and so on.
Whereas where as best interests
have to do with the sorts of things,
it would be absurd to think the state
would be any good at knowing your child,
child, caring deeply about your
child, wanting your child to survive,
having what we called Olia
interdependent utilities, um,
that it connected to your
child's welfare and thriving.
Those are not things that can come
from government officials almost by
definition because they involve
things like care and affection. Um,
and all of the,
the things that make a a s make
for the super abundant good,
uh, of, of rearing a happy
child to have been realized.
And one of the indeed when you think about
what is it that we think of as tragic
when a child winds up in it being raised
in an orphanage is precisely that,
that that is missing,
that they,
they're being raised by people
who are not into kick to,
do not cap passionately and
intimately about them. Um,
so you can see why it would make obvious
and intuitive sense to think of parents
as the guardians of, um, if I'd use Eri,
guardians of Children's best
interests. Why should the state, uh,
be the fied usury guardian of the basic
interests apart from the fact that we
don't want us have one hierarchy?
Well,
there's certain kinds of things parents
might choose to do out of convictions
about children's best interests that have
an impact on their capacity to survive
and thrive,
um,
as members of a democratic policy polity.
And as able,
as able to function in the economic
system as it's likely do exist for their
lifetime.
The Amish chose in a famous case,
Wisconsin versus Yoda.
They wanted to keep their kids
out of school after age 14.
Even though the state of Wisconsin through
its democratic mechanisms had decided
that you really need to go to school to
the age of age 16 in order to learn the
skills necessary to participate
in the political order.
And it's in the economy as it's
likely to exist for your lifetime.
The Amish didn't dispute that,
but what they said was,
we have learned from experience that if
we allow our kids to go to school after
age 14, the odds that they will
leave the Amish community go way up.
Well, that's not a good argument, uh,
for allowing them to prevent
their kids getting an education.
And so I think the Supreme Court
made the wrong choice when it agreed,
uh,
with the parents in that case or think
of a different one where Christian
scientists are of the view that a child
in need of a blood transfusion shouldn't
get it because of their religious beliefs.
And this is a case again where
I would argue eventually,
um, if you can persuade them,
the parents should lose the, the,
the state has an,
has a fide use Eri obligation to the
child to allow it to survive and not
suffer the consequences of
not having a life saving, uh,
transformed, um, uh, blood transfusion.
On the other hand, there are, there
are other cases we could talk about,
for instance,
parents might object and have objected
to certain kinds of books being used in
the schools that where the goal is to
promote literacy on the grounds that they
object to the moral message within in
the books and they go to court and they
challenge the use of certain kinds of
books that convey moral messages that the
parents find objectionable.
And in cases like that, um,
the burden should fall to the school
district to show there's some other way
that, to show that there isn't some other
way they could meet their obligation to
teach literacy that didn't infringe
on the parent's best interests,
uh,
conception of the child's best interests,
which includes their moral education.
So in those kinds of cases,
the parents should win.
There will sometimes be murky cases.
There will sometimes be
disagreements about, um,
whether or not the state is vindicating
the basic interests in a way that's as
inobtrusive as possible,
as the parent's capacity to
meet the best interest. And I,
I think you have to create procedural
mechanisms in which those disagreements
are played out.
Uh,
and much of that chapter that I had you
read for today is concerned with what
those procedural mechanisms might be.
It's also the case that
it might change over time.
So for example,
we might initially think that things
like sex education belong in the area of
best interest because of the
soft girl has to do with, um,
the system of morality that apparent
wants to communicate to their child.
Um,
and you have the pluralism of values.
Different parents have different
value systems and that's um,
understood and therefore we don't want,
um,
one moral code to be forced on all
children about matters of sexual morality.
And that could be the
status quo for a long time.
But then along comes aids and suddenly
sexual morality becomes a public health
matter.
And so it then may we cast how we would
think about the division of [inaudible]
area authority between parents and
the state over the sexual education of
children. And because it pumps
up public health issue, um,
it may be the case that one would insist
on certain kinds of sex education,
uh,
going on in the schools,
although it would have to be designed
to be as inobtrusive intrusive as
possible, uh, of the parents conception
of the children's best interest.
And they'll tussle about
that, they'll disagree about
it, they'll go to court. Um,
but it's,
uh,
that is a healthy tousle from the point
of view of the larger conception of
democratic justice because really what
you want to do is have a system in which
both hierarchical orders,
namely the parental fiduciary order and
the public fiduciary theory order are to
some extent held accountable,
uh,
and checked by the claims of one another.
And so, um, this is,
this is one institutional model and it's
actually not that different from the
one that, that exists in the US today.
When you, when you think about it that,
um,
the state does reserve authority over
children's basic interests and when
parents become physically abusive
or endanger the life of a child,
we will step in and do something.
But short of that, um, for,
for many very good reasons,
uh,
we leave the parent to decide the
best interest of the child immune from
interference by the state.
And we try to create mechanisms
that limit the ways in which,
if I do, sorry, uh, interest
of the state of indicated. Um,
so it was to allow the freest
possible hand of course,
the huge areas of controversy with this.
Um,
because often the state will delegate
its authority over basic interest of
parents and so we'll allow private
schools and that sort of thing.
And then we have to manage the result
and um, knock on effects of that,
uh, when the, when the school system
fails, uh, or it doesn't, uh, it,
it, it teaches things that are in
at fundamental odds with the, uh,
with the principles of
a democratic society.
And those sorts of
tensions are inevitable.
Once you have a dual regime system.
And you need to create mechanisms,
whether it's courts, war,
systems of administrative appeal,
uh,
or whatever it might be in
which these parties can, um,
check one another and
hold them to account.
Because the state has so much more power.
I argue the burden should often
be, uh, adjusted accordingly.
And it should be easier for parents to
challenge what public officials do than
the other way around.
Uh,
and so you get into find nuances of
institutional design that are intended to
accommodate the basic power disparities.
But so that's,
that is if you like a,
a,
an adapted Lockian view of how one would
think about governance over children
that is modified by the,
the principles of democratic justice.
Let's switch and talk
about employment relations.
Very different world.
We're now dealing with competent
adults who are presumed
to know their own interests.
We don't need to have a fight,
use area arrangements and paternalistic
judgments and wall. And we,
we can imagine a system in which everybody
takes care of their own interests.
Now, if you think about
the governance of the firm,
as I said, uh, firms are
hierarchical organizations,
um, in which employees have to
do what employers tell them.
Uh,
this is generally thought to be efficient.
There are debates about whether,
MMM,
firms are too hierarchical.
If they become too high rocket called,
they may become less efficient.
And indeed in the 1960s and seventies,
there was a, there was a, uh,
a movement trying to argue
that democratically run
firms would be more efficient
than hierarchically ordered firms.
Huge literature on that.
Uh, but the best book on the subject
was written by Henry Hansman.
Now in the Yale law school. Um, my book,
which I commend to you all called
the ownership of enterprise,
which I discussed some in that chapter,
uh, on democracy in the workplace.
And hansman pointed out that
if democratically run firms,
we're more efficient,
we would have seen them emerge
all over the economy, right? If,
if democratically run
firms were more efficient,
they would have out competed
the hierarchical firm.
MMM.
And indeed in the sixties and seventies,
part of the reason people made those
arguments was they observed that Japanese
firms were much less
hierarchical than American firms.
And also they thought they
were much more efficient.
They will all these studies showing,
you know,
Japanese car firms had
three layers of management,
whereas American carm firms had seven
layers of management and Japanese cars
firms.
We're more efficient.
That didn't look so good after the 1990s
rolled in and Japanese firms turned out
not to be very efficient at all.
There was similar arguments about, um, uh,
what a Ph to be democratic firms in a
part of Italy called monitor gone that was
thought be very efficient.
But,
but a subsequent studies showed that
actually these firms were not very
democratic,
critically run at all and they were
basically controlled by the banks that
controlled there, um, capitol. And so, um,
it was a rather naive to
expect democratic, uh,
firms to be efficient.
And indeed,
as Henry Hansman points out,
you only really find that
democratic firms are efficient
in circumstances where everybody has,
can do every job like law firms or taxi
cab companies or plywood cooption and
northeastern, Northwestern us, um,
where everybody has an
interchangeable role,
then democracy doesn't come
at any cost to efficiency.
Um, this is a combination of the
ancient ruling and being ruled.
In turn, if we can all do everything
right, we can all we can, we can,
uh, be egalitarian about it. And, um,
the Buchanan and Telec observation that
I talked to you about earlier, namely,
when we have disagreements and you create
a lot of procedure that will be time
consuming, be precisely
because we have disagreements,
we have different interests.
So hansman says in large firms or firms
where you have old workers and young
workers, they'll have very different
interests on things like pensions.
Young workers were one, one thing, old
workers, well, one, something else. Um,
and if you start to have a lot of
democratic procedure in those kinds of
circumstances,
it's going to come at an efficiency cost
because they're going to be sitting in
meetings all day arguing about their
pension benefits and not working on the
assembly line.
So it's not surprising hansman
saves that in most industries.
In fact,
you do not get democratic
firms for efficiency reasons.
Efficiency is the superordinate good,
right?
Firms have there to produce goods
and services that make money. Uh,
and if you don't do it efficiently,
we'll be more efficiently than the
next person you're going to go out of
business. So from the point
of view of pure efficiency,
mmm.
It seems like you're not going to
get a lot of democracy in the firm.
That's the cold, harsh reality
from this perspective of 2010.
And the literature advocating democratic
firms has this kind of come by our
quality that,
um,
it's difficult to take seriously
in the contemporary world.
Firms are going to be hierarchical,
then we have the problem. Well,
so how should we think about the
hierarchies within firms given the that,
okay.
MMM.
Given the fact that they are sites of
greatly unequal distribution of power.
So different players
have different options.
For instance, if you, and this is
where I would disagree with hand Smith,
if you,
if you're a shareholder
in a firm and you don't
like what the firm is doing,
you have a very easy option,
right?
You can just sell your shares and buy
shares and another firm, right? Yeah,
no problem there. All right. And so, um,
Hansman says we should think of
shareholders as enforcing democratic
accountability and firms. I don't think
that's a very plausible way to go.
Um, because shareholders
have very low exit costs.
Um, you simply, you don't
like the way a farm is wine.
You buy shares in a different firm.
They're not going to exercise
much democratic control
of what goes on within the
firm.
Think about employees in a firm.
Well,
it depends a lot on the situation.
So just to fix intuitions,
consider this,
why do I talk about a surface paradise?
The Belgian political philosophy.
Um,
Phillip Farm per race wrote a book called
Real Freedom for all in which he said,
um, it's a kind of post roles in
book about Justice Fund per rice.
He writes, he run something by the way,
called the basic income network. Um,
which I urge you to take a look at
this website. It's quite interesting.
He basically says everybody should
be paid the highest sustainable wage
regardless of work.
This is sort of Sweden on
crack or something. Okay.
Everybody should be paid. The
highest, even surface should be paid.
That's on per Rice's
view that everybody is.
In European parlance,
it's called the social way.
They should have the highest
social wage possible. Okay?
So imagine that that's a surface paradise.
This is the utopia on per race.
Just friends in that book.
Real freedom for all think at
the other end of a continuum,
what we might call a Dickensian nightmare.
A world in which there's
no health insurance,
no unemployment insurance,
no welfare state, no
social security, nothing,
okay?
So obviously every actual economy exists
somewhere on this continuum from the
Dickensian nightmare to this,
to the paradise.
And so what I want to say as well that
affects a lot of what goes on within the
firm
because
if we are living in a
Dickensian nightmare,
go back to the example
I mentioned last time.
Thank you for an employer
who's in a hierarchical
relationship with as secretary
and says to the secretary,
unless you go to bed with me,
I'm going to make sure you get fired.
So now an employer is abusing
the position in the hierarchy,
right? Well, if this is
a Dickensian nightmare,
the secretary is going to be terrified
because the costs,
I'm losing that job on enormous,
going to lose their health insurance is
no unemployment, et Cetera, et Cetera,
et cetera. You're going
to be thrown out into, um,
a pretty horrible cauldron if
you're living in a surface.
Paradise secretary can just can walk away,
right at much lower cost to themselves.
And I'm not talking about
the question whether this,
this the secretary is actually
fired or actually walks away,
but simply the knowledge both parties
have that that in the Dickensian nightmare
that the exit cost for the
secretary of our enormous,
whereas in the surface paradise, the exit
costs for the secretary, I'm very low,
right. That structures the
power relations within the firm.
So the basic intuition here
is when we ask the question,
how much should the state regulate?
What goes on in firms?
The answer is, well, it depends.
It depends upon where you
are on this continuum.
Because if you're closer
to a surface paradise,
there's rec last reason for the state to
create lots of protections for workers
within the firm,
which are going to come at an
efficiency cost by assumption, right?
Appeals Processes, defenses,
Defense of union rights,
grievance procedures,
burden shifting to employers
when there are disputes,
all of that comes at an efficiency cost,
right?
But so the notion is that if
it's a Dickensian nightmare,
the work is basic
interests are threatened,
then
democratic justice would not say the
workers should internalize those costs.
We added the employer. Should, but
you move towards a surface paradise,
then there's more reason to say that,
um,
the worker can internalize some of the
costs of hierarchy in the firm because
the costs of leaving a
comparatively smaller.
And so you have, uh, as I said,
a semi contextual argument what this
regime should be like depends on the power
externalities within which the power
internal realities of the firm actually
take place.
And one of the desirable
features of this I think is, um,
that it,
it leads,
leads you to rethink relationship
between capital and labor.
You know, Mark's thought that's the
basic conflict work as on one side,
capital on the other.
But now if you think,
say about something like health insurance,
we have a system now where health
insurance is provided through employment,
which moved moves you in more than a
Dickensian nightmare direction, right?
Because you don't use, you lose your job,
you lose your health insurance, right?
And employers compete with one
another by offering, you know,
Yale says too,
we off a Betta Betta health benefits
then working for whatever it is,
Harvard or, or, um, Columbia.
So employers compete with one another,
right?
But the truth is all of the employers
would be better off if there were,
if they didn't have to compete in
everybody had health insurance. Right?
So there there's a kind of collective
action problem, what looks like,
especially once we get into strikes and
bargaining disputes between employees
and employers.
What looks like a conflict between
capital and labor couldn't be
reconceptualized as what it is really.
It's a collective action
problem among firms, right?
They all compete at the margin
over things like benefits.
But in fact they would be better off
if health benefits would taken off the
table entirely and funded
through the tax system. Um,
so what looks like a conflict between
capital and labor is actually the
collective action problem among firms.
And the other advantage of this
I think is that it does not put
the best in conflict with
the good in that if you,
to the extent you have a regime like this,
you give firms the incentive to support
the expansion of the social wage.
Because what do,
what do capitalists want?
What a manager's want most, they
want flexibility. At the plant level,
they want to be able to turn on a dime
and lay off people and do something
differently and compete in the
21st century in a totally new way.
Then they will competing two years
before because that's what you need.
The name of the game is flexibility,
adaptability, nimbleness, all that stuff.
That's what firms want. That's
what they need, right? And the,
if they know that the closer you
you get to a Dickensian nightmare,
the more cumbersome regulation they're
going to have and the more you would move
toward the surface paradise,
the last you're going to have.
Then they have an incentive to try and
move the society toward the surface
paradise.
So corporations will get behind
expansions of health insurance and so on.
And there's a certain realism to that
because if you go and study the history of
the expansion of the welfare state,
despite what you might
read in the newspapers,
what you will find is it never happens
unless business gets behind it.
The big expansions of the social wage,
the big expansions of the welfare state,
even in countries like Sweden have only
occurred in circumstances where business
gets behind it and supports it.
So you want,
you want an industrial management regime
that distributes the incentives in such
a way that they will do it.
So those are two examples of how we
can think about democratizing the power
dimensions of,
of uh,
social institutions while interfering
with the superordinate goods as little as
possible.
And that's the basic impulse of
the argument of democratic justice.
If you take a step back and you think
about democracy over the past couple of
centuries, you know, we, I talked to
you some about Alexis de Tocqueville.
He made two points about democracy.
He had a love hate relationship with it.
I told you he was in
many ways a credit covet,
but he did say two things about it.
One that it was inevitable,
the gradual progress if democracy,
he said in the preface to the 1848 edition
of democracy in America is something
faded. It, it's his
providential, I can't be stopped.
And the other thing he said is that the
thing about democracy is it has wild
instincts. What we need to do is try
and domesticate it, not get rid of it.
We can't get rid of it. We can't
stop it. So we must domesticate it.
Well, I think both of those
claims were partly correct.
It is true.
Tocqueville was correct to think that
democracy is an idea with world historical
force.
Um,
it will always be appealed to by people
who experience injustice and they will
always a demand democratization,
um,
if they,
they find their social set
circumstances on satisfactory.
So I think this notion,
uh, is partly right,
but even though democracy is an
idea with world historical force,
I think he was partly wrong to say that
the progress of democracy is inevitable.
There have always been advances
for democracy and then setbacks.
Uh, we had this French revolution.
We had a disease state in 1830.
We had a democratic
revolution sweep Europe by,
by 1832, the monarchies
had been restored. 1848.
Again, we had democratic
revolution sweep Europe. Uh,
and by 1851,
they had been undone.
1989,
we had democratic revolutions,
huge new wave of democracy.
But some of those democracies came
under real threat in places like, uh,
fell apart in
Algeria in 1991.
Uh,
we know what happened in Rwanda.
Um,
although things have turned
around again since, well,
if we look at Pakistan in the
last three or four years, uh,
we see that,
that we shouldn't think of
democracy as inevitable.
This sort of Francis Fukuyama idea
that history is to intending in some
direction, uh, to the extent
you think democracy is valuable,
really what you have to do is
work to promote it and sustain it.
Likewise, when we talk about
Tocqueville, second observation,
that democracy has wild instincts
and it needs to be reined in a,
we need to, as he put it, educate
democracy, uh, to limit its,
it's wild instincts and make sure that
it doesn't destroy other good things.
Superordinate goods.
In his case, of course,
freedom was the most important good that
he didn't want democracy to compromise.
But I think the same argument
applies with respect to efficiency,
with respect to um, many of the
superordinate goods that people
strive the after and cherish.
So we always have to be weary of the
capacity of democracy to undermine other
goods. But, and this is where I think
Tocqueville overstated the case,
that does not mean we
should overlook democracies,
capacity to undermine
bad things in the world.
Um,
to the extent we can democratize power
relations without interfering with
superordinate goods,
we can have a tremendous effect for good.
Whether it's the abolition of slavery,
whether it's the limiting of
exploitation in the workplace,
whether it's the protection or the
restructuring of the law of marriage to
prevent, um, the domination of women.
These are all areas in which the basic
democratic impulse to democratize social
relations has improved them.
And so it doesn't mean it
will always be successful.
Sometimes it will fail,
requires creative ingenuity,
the capacity to try things out and
change them when they don't work.
Um,
but the basic impulse of democratic
justice is to take inherited institutions,
um, democratize them as we
reproduce them into the future,
leaving a better world than we found.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible].